y la regulación de la expresión génica
se puede modular en prácticamente
cualquier etapa del proceso desde el
inicio de la transcripción hasta la
modificación post traducción al de una
proteína y en cada etapa intermedia y es
la capacidad de regular todos estos
diferentes pasos lo que ayuda a la
célula a tener la versatilidad y la
adaptabilidad de un ninja eficiente de
modo que gasta energía para expresar las
proteínas apropiadas solo cuando es
necesario o podemos pensar en la célula
como un ente perezoso que quiere gastar
la menor cantidad de energía posible
entonces comenzando por el principio de
la expresión génica hablemos sobre la
regulación génica en lo que respecta a
la regulación del adn y la cromatina
veamos la estructura del adn el adn está
empaquetado en los cromosomas en forma
de cromatina también conocida como adn
super enrollado la cromatina está
compuesta de adn proteinas histonas y
proteínas no histonas y hay unidades
repetidas en la cromatina llamadas
núcleos son más que están formadas por
146 pares de bases de adn helicoidal
doble que se envuelve alrededor
un núcleo de 8 histonas y hay cuatro
tipos diferentes de histonas dentro de
esta estructura de 8 que debemos tener
en cuenta se llaman h 2a h 2b h3 y h
esa es la nomenclatura que les han dado
ahora la acetilación ocurre en las colas
amino terminales de estas proteínas de
histonas por una enzima llamada histona
acetil transferasa que abreviar como h
ate y esta es una modificación
reversible por lo que la acetilación de
histonas se mantiene en equilibrio por
otra enzima que elimina estos grupos
hace ti lo que se llama histona
deacetilasa o hd hace la acetilación de
las histonas conduce al desenrolla
miento de esta estructura de cromatina y
esto permite que se acceda mediante
maquinaria transcripcional para la
expresión de genes por otro lado la de
sacyl acción de histonas conduce a una
estructura condensada o cerrada de la
cromatina y a una menor transcripción de
esos genes cuando estas modificaciones
que regulan la expresión génica son
heredables se denominan regulación
epigenética entonces cuando se trata de
la
génica y del adn básicamente se puede
pensar que el adn viene en dos sabores
adn densamente empaquetados y
transcripción al mente y nativo que se
llama éter o cromatina y luego adn menos
denso y transcripción al mente activo
que es el cromatina y me gusta pensar
que la hetero cromatina está densamente
comprimida hibernando ya que la hetero
cromatina y la hibernación comienzan con
h
me imagino esto como un grupo de osos
densamente comprimidos que están
encerrados en su cueva durante el
invierno mientras que la eu koroma tina
espera allí con los brazos abiertos
dando la bienvenida a la maquinaria
transcripcional para ser transcritas
ahora a menudo verán que la de sacyl
acción de histonas se combina con otro
tipo de mecanismo regulador de adn y que
es la metilación del adn y esto ocurre
en un proceso llamado silenciamiento
génico y este es un método más
permanente para regular la transcripción
de genes la metilación del adn implica
la adición de un grupo metilo que es un
carbono con tres hidrógenos
la citosina o nucleótidos de adn por una
enzima llamada apropiadamente
metiltransferasa y esto ocurre
típicamente en secuencias ricas en
citocinas llamadas islas cpg no
olvidemos que la citosina se combina con
la guanina por eso son islas
cg la metilación del adn altera de
manera estable la expresión de los genes
por lo que ocurre cuando las células se
dividen y diferencian de las células
madre embrionarias en tejidos
específicos por lo tanto esto es
esencial para el desarrollo normal y
está asociado con otros procesos como la
impronta genómica y la inactivación del
cromosoma x temas para otra discusión y
la metilación anormal del adn se ha
implicado en las carcinogénesis o
desarrollo de cáncer por lo que podemos
ver por qué el funcionamiento normal de
la metilación del adn es un mecanismo
regulador crítico para nuestras células
ahora la metilación del adn puede
afectar la transcripción de genes de dos
maneras primero la metilación del adn en
sí misma puede impedir físicamente la
unión de las
transcripcionales al gen y en segundo
lugar y más importante el adn metilado
puede estar unido a proteínas conocidas
como proteínas de dominio de unión a
metil cpg o mdb para abreviar las
proteínas mdb pueden reclutar proteínas
adicionales para el locus o la ubicación
particular de un cromosoma ciertos genes
como las histonas de esas y plazas y
otras proteínas de remodelación de la
cromatina y esto modifica las histonas
formando hetero cromatina condensada e
inactiva que es básicamente
transcripción al mente silenciosa